Після ліквідації ДАІ у 2015 році
поліцейські фактично зникли з трас міжнародного і державного значення в Україні.
Через це, кажуть у Нацполіції,
значно збільшилася кількість ДТП.
Тому створили нову дорожню патрульну поліцію.
Вона, по суті, виконуватиме функції ліквідованих ДАІ
із забезпечення безпеки дорожнього руку.
Але є й відмінності.
Приміром, дорожня поліція не матиме права
без причини зупиняти автівку для перевірки.
Та головна відмінність полягає в тому, що  дорожня поліція,
на противагу ДАІ і, власне, патрульній поліції,
працюватиме виключно за містом,
на трасах державного і міжнародного значення.
Нова служба на відміну від ДАІ не буде влаштовувати "засади в кущах".
Більшість свого часу вони мають працювати в режимі патрулювання
і їздити на трасах.
На відміну від даїшників, нові дорожні інспектори
матимуть відеокамери
для фіксації того, що відбувається під час служби.
Замість "смугастої палки"ДАІ
дорожнім патрульним вручать жезли з червоним диском на кінці.
У Нацполіції вважають – їх краще видно на дорозі.
Водії вже встигли назвати нову палицю - льодяником.
У майбутньому патрульні автомобілі планують обладнати
сучасними приладами вимірювання швидкості.
Якщо водій перевищив швидкість,
його зупинятимуть і одразу на місці виписуватимуть штраф,
а не присилатимуть згодом так званого "листя щастя",
як це відбувається при стаціонарній автофіксації.
Окрім того, відновлять свою роботу і старі стаціонарні пости,
які належали раніше ДАІ.
Там планують обладнати сервісні пункти надання допомоги водіям.
Станом на нині по всій країні діють вісім таких постІв.
Загалом до кінця року планують набрати 2300 інспекторів
для роботи в дорожній поліції.
Щоправда, у Нацполіції не люблять порівнювати старі ДАІ
з новою дорожньою поліцією.
Там кажуть, що нова служба
не має жодного відношення до даішників.
Мовляв, це ті самі патрульні поліцейські,
які просто працюватимуть на трасах за містом.